you mentioned air quest and people
should listen to your conversation with
Eric as a fascinating one is great uh
it's non-standard it just goes all over
the place in this humor and wait it's
great so one interesting aspect that I
also learned perhaps not about you but
about Eric about both but
Eric has a similar thing as with Jordan
Peterson
which is
if you ask him do they believe in God I
think the answer they're not comfortable
answering that question or they might
say no but they're usually just not
comfortable answering that question but
there's a kind of sense that they would
like to live life a religious life as if
God exists I think that's exactly right
I think first of all Eric has a really
deep appreciation of the Jewish
tradition I don't know Peterson I've
read his stuff and I've reviewed his
stuff and so on but I think that
jungians are in their very approach they
believe that myth is the way the world
works and so it's not that big a leap to
God but it's still there's still a
distance there is it possible to have
your cake and eat it too is it possible
to have the depth
of a religious life without believing in
God like how do you make sense of Eric
Weinstein's uh devout life within the
tradition I mean I honestly think he
believes in God but doesn't believe in
God and it's oscillating like it's a
quantum mechanical system of some sort
Schrodinger's got
um so I think that he would probably
agree with what uh Ellie Wiesel said
that that a Jew can can be angry at God
or be disbelieving of God but is not
allowed to be indifferent to God and I
think Eric's not indifferent to God
um and and it's different than
Christianity I've had this conversation
many times because you can be very
Jewish and have deep doubts about
theological questions because Judaism
isn't a religion it's a religious family
and so you're born Jewish like if I said
to you tomorrow if I was Christian and I
said oh I believe in Jesus today and
then tomorrow I didn't I'm not Christian
anymore but if tomorrow I said I don't
believe all this stuff I'm still Jewish
so it's a more complicated
system having said that though
I think it's very hard to sustain over
Generations without some belief that the
source of it is beyond ourselves and and
in that sense as in many others Eric is
unique
well he was actually making that claim
that we need
faith to uh propagate this tradition
through the generations yeah so without
that the Traditions crumble it's a very
interesting idea
a very interesting argument for devout
Faith which is it's a thing it's a glue
that holds a tradition together
otherwise like traditions fall apart
right so you can't have the intensity
um of that tradition I mean on the other
hand you do see tradition I mean
Thanksgiving one of my favorite
so I would say Traditions that are
demanding Fall Apart
to Traditions that that require turkey
might not fall apart but Traditions that
are that make demands of you that are
counter-cultural or are hard they fall
apart I think I need to introduce you to
some Thanksgiving dinners that that are
quite demanding getting the family
together you know there's a first of all
I'm a vegetarian so I'm tough to have at
Thanksgiving dinner but there's a
there's a comedian named Kathy landsman
who one year I heard this on the radio
and it stuck with me she said that uh
that holidays are a chance to renew your
resentments afresh you know and that's
basically what people do with their
families it's like I'm gonna go home and
fight with the uncle again this year